pardon non c'est pas mal
un sont familiers n'est ce pas
aujourd'hui on est tous connectés en
numérique sur twitter instagram youtube
ou encore netflix des applications à
tout va ce même numérique peut parfois
nous séparer d ancienne génération
semaine numérique peut aussi nous
séparent et parfois de nos parents de
nos grands-parents
cela se traduit dont le fameux débat
entre les générations x y z ou encore
baby boomer vous avez sûrement entendu
parler ou entendu dire vos parents ou
grands parents
vous les djeuns les petits geeks vous
les appelez peut-être les darons au même
les petits vieux autant d'appellations
qui ont la même finalité celle de
séparer et différencier les générations
aujourd'hui les études scientifiques
montrent que dans une entreprise on peut
retrouver trois formes des générations
trois générations qui doivent cohabiter
et travailler ensemble au quotidien
et si je vous disais que le numérique
peut également vous concilié avec les
anciennes générations
et si je vous disais que vos compétences
et connaissances en matière
d'applications téléphoniques mais aussi
en matière du digital peuvent vous
rapprocher d'un directeur ou du membre
de la direction d'une grande entreprise
et oui aujourd'hui de plus en plus
d'entreprises réalisent le rôle
fondamental du numérique pour rapprocher
les nra les générations un outil qui est
proposé est celui du rival ce monitoring
qu'on appelle aussi le mentorat inversée
j'ai eu ce constat révélateur
durant une conférence de réseautage vous
connaissez ces événements ces fameux
événement où l'on rencontre des
personnes qu'on ne connaît pas du tout
qui viennent de différents secteurs
d'activité donc à l'époque j'étais
fraîchement diplômés j'avais beaucoup de
motivation de l'espoir un peu comme
certains parmi vous aujourd'hui sur mon
et donc je me sentais invincible j'ai
participé à cette conférence et quelque
part j'avais une sensation très paradis
paradoxal je me sentais tout petit sans
aucune crédibilité avec mon diplôme de
master entouré de personnes qui sont
plus âgés que moi qui ont fait de plus
longues études qui ont beaucoup plus
d'expérience que moi et qui
appartiennent à de très grandes
entreprises
donc vous savez j'ai joué à l'étudiante
invisible vous connaissez cette
sensation vous vous mettez au fond de la
salle vous observez vous dit rien j'ai
pris une toute petite place à la fin et
j'ai observé
donc il y avait des témoignages tout le
monde parlait de son expérience ses
échecs
les réussites également et quelque part
parmi ces témoignages j'ai réalisé qu'il
y avait un point en commun tout le monde
partage et finalement un seul problème
je dirais plutôt un seul défi celui de
faire face à la transformation digitale
la transformation digitale de leur
métier la transformation digitale de
leur entreprise au même de la société
il y avait une dame qui n'avait
particulièrement marqué à l'époque donc
c'était une dame qui avait fait part de
son envie de changer d'entreprise
après 30 ans d'expérience 30 ans
d'ancienneté et tout ce qu'elle voulait
c'était de faire une reconversion
professionnelle
alors elle ne savais pas du tout comment
s'y prendre elle ne savait pas comment
mettre en valeur son expérience elle ne
savait pas comment valoriser ses
compétences
alors moi depuis mon siège tout au fond
naturellement j'ai pensé à linkedin au
mode de réseautage je me suis dit elle
pourra peut-être créer un petit blog ou
un petit site internet ou même un compte
instagram professionnel pourquoi pas
pour valoriser sa visibilité sur la
toile
donc à la fin de la conférence je suis
allée la voir
et oui j'ai osé cette fois je suis allé
la voir pour lui faire part de mes idées
et durant la discussion à la sortie son
carnet
elle a commencé à noter mes idées vous
vous rendez compte
elle noté mes idées il s'agissait
d'aider tellement simple et tellement
évidente pour moi et pour elle ça avait
l'air très important c'est là où j'ai
réalisé que finalement ce qui me
paraissait intuitif et très faciles à
appliquer ne l'était pas forcément pour
tout le monde je revois encore cette
dame aujourd'hui je les aider à mettre
en place un site internet pour
développer son activité
mais le plus important c'est que elle
aussi elle m'a aidé elle m'a aidée grâce
à sa connaissance du marché de travail
grâce à son ancienneté elle assume
orienté elle a su m'écouter quand j'en
avais besoin
et elle a contribué à développer mon
carnet d'adressés
on a eu des échanges sur différents
sujets personnelle comme professionnelle
elle m'a appris par exemple l'importance
des capacités des compétences
relationnelles
elle m'a aussi appris la capacité
d'adaptation à n'importe quel
environnement professionnel
c'était un échange inter générationnelle
c'était un échange qui m'a permis
d'évoluer mais saha lui a aussi permis
d'évoluer donc chacune à sa façon
mon expérience n'est pas la seule en
matière de mentorat les entreprises
aujourd'hui réalise de plus en plus
l'importance de cette pratique qui est
fondamental les digital natives donc
vous a priori vous devenez les mentors
dans les entreprises
les cadres dirigeants eux ils deviennent
les mentors et vos mentors et finalement
sans un lien intergénérationnel qui
semble gagnant gagnant donc un
transmission de savoir où le jeune il va
apprendre à appuyer sa présence dans
l'entreprise et a développé également sa
légitimité et le seigneur de l'autre
côté il va apprendre à maîtriser une
thématique qui est primordial pour
l'avenir de l'entreprise qui est le
digital
alors je vous demande pourquoi ne pas
adopter le rivers manteau ring
tous les jours pourquoi ne pas valoriser
le ton passé sur vos applications
téléphoniques
pourquoi ne pas développer davantage ses
compétences digitales au service de
votre avenir professionnel
c'était isaac newton qui disait si j'ai
vu plus loin
c'est en montant sur les épaules de
géants alors pourquoi ne pas valoriser
vos compétences digitales pour monter
sur les épaules de géants ou encore
mieux pourquoi ne pas devenir le géant
lui même alors croyez en votre capacité
de changer le monde même à votre petite
échelle
merci
[Applaudissements]